ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
silicon valley scammers in this episode
we're talking about
the poop testing company revolutionizing
the human biome
it's a company called you biome and this
is their founder
now after the fraud has been uncovered
they're on the run
yes her her and her co-founder are
literally their warrants out for their
arrest and they are fugitives
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla
and today we're talking about you biome
now
like i said uh they're poop testers
which is a bit weird but okay that's
fine it's a thing guys we all poop and
let me say right off the bat
you're gonna notice some immediate
comparisons natural comparisons to
elizabeth holmes which we talked about
in episode
one and if i were you if i'm netflix
right
i'd be shooting for the elizabeth home
story obviously it's the best story
but if i'm like one of the lessers
watching the show if i'm like a
director for like showtime or something
and i'm looking for a hot new doc
go with you buy them don't be afraid to
dip into the number two
uh no pun intended because this story is
honestly pretty amazing
all on its own listen one thing that i
found interesting right off the bat and
we'll just like draw comparisons as we
go
so elizabeth holmes uh she was doing a
ted med talk in 2014.
i believe right remember this individual
is the answer
is cheese dude she's the worst uh but
in 2013 so that's 2014 ted bed
ted med just loves hosting the
charlatans because uh
this is jessica richmond giving another
rah-rah you know uh science talk
we're all gonna be saved by these new
silicon valley people
rediscovering medicine and that's what
she does with the talk in tedmed
scientists win a nobel prize no really
this is a real question
can a citizen scientist win a nobel
prize can a citizen scientist
go to jail for fraud it's a real
question
a sea change is happening in science the
technological forces that are
globalizing and connecting and
integrating all of us
are increasingly bringing us together to
do science buzz buzz buzz buzz buzz bye
guys
the increasing globalization globalizing
forces
there's a sea change going on listen
it's all fine
there's nothing wrong with buzzwords but
you gotta have something to back it up
so she pitches you buy em which actually
hilariously
started on kickstarter and indiegogo yes
that's right
this kind of belongs in a in gofundme
garbage episode
truthfully i didn't know where to put it
did i put it in silicon valley scams
do i put it in gofundme garbage it's the
same thing
uh reaffirming my long-held belief that
gofundmes kickstarters
indiegogos 99 crap again no pun intended
dang i'm on a roll today
one take baby this is one take so uh
what else with jessica well there's a
lot more
so just like elizabeth holmes was known
for faking her voice
jessica richmond also faked her own
stuff she
faked her age she lied about her age
when she was like 46 to go ahead and get
into the women's 30 under 30 list
or she oh sorry 40. so she was trying to
get into
the list so she goes yeah i'm like 30 or
something and she's actually 40 years
old
how silly is that that's so goofy man
and then she got on the list and then
solicited investors with it
like the startup founders made sure
investors got uh those articles
according to prosecutors
so she it's all about lying your way to
the top you find out
with um these con artists which is that
it's the same pattern of
kind of like sketchy you know
morals you know lying when it's
convenient that's what you see
over and over with these people now
something else they lied about was also
their marketing materials
so you know how i call out fakers all
the time for using stock photos
hey guess what you biome did the same
thing
it's not just codmin in the fake guru
space it's also silicon valley
so-called revolutionaries that aren't
afraid to use a good old
stock photo when convenient now they say
these testimonials really
do exist smart gut has played a huge
part in helping me create my l plan
based on my unique needs
but other people say it was basically
like a horoscope i mean it's like the
technology really wasn't there to tell
you
many meaningful things and ultimately in
um the the report from
the doj or excuse me the sec you end up
finding out that basically it all boiled
down to an insurance
fraud scheme which is kind of pathetic
for all this work
about revolutionary we're changing
everything it's just an insurance scheme
uh to get doctors to order patients
tests they don't need
and maybe that's the most boring part
about all of this but honestly it's
interesting to realize that this is
actually
what's criminal about what they did
because they've been recently charged in
a new complaint
that um yeah they're gonna they're
facing criminal charges not just
civil charges conspiracy to commit
health care fraud health care fraud
aggravated identity theft conspiracy to
commit wirefraud you get the idea just
your
average silicon valley charges and uh
maybe the most interesting part about
all of this is that they're actually
right now
fugitives i was looking at the documents
and you see jessica richmond
is not in custody has not been arrested
and
is a fugitive and in fact ladies and
gentlemen there's currently
a warrant out for her arrest
as well as her partner um zachary you
see here
that zachary is also a fugitive so
ladies and gentlemen i mean
theron's thing yes it's very interesting
but that story has already been told i
feel like
this story is only beginning it's an
international manhunt where are these
people
they've committed fraud and they run off
after stealing everyone's poop maybe
that was the
maybe that was their big plan
listen i don't know does it sound like a
crappy movie or is it good
let me know i think it'd be great
contact me netflix or showtime or amazon
private i'm
honestly this is an amazon primer let's
be honest it's not at that level it's
not a netflix but
amazon prime call me we'll set something
up in the meantime guys i hope you
enjoyed
this episode of silicon valley scams let
me know what you want to see in the
future
that's basically it and i will see you
guys
next time i know what you need this
ain't what it seems
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee